[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are continuing our
series friendship throughout the years
with moving into the middle school year
so we started last time talking about
elementary school now we're moving on to
middle school which for us was seventh
and eighth grade just a two-year period
but a very substantial two-year period
in our lives and in our friendship
developmentally and yeah i the fact that
we're do you get pubes looking at things
oh that's a teaser sure i'll uh i'll
weigh in on that one
i entered with pubes looking just so you
know looking at it through came right
through the seventh grade door with
pubes i'm making a point oh sorry sorry
sorry i'm making pube jokes yeah i
really don't want to talk about okay
please
that's why i like graciously say oh it's
a teaser meaning we'll talk about that
later and maybe he'll forget oh no i
won't now but it seems that you want to
talk about it now i like having this
series because it
recontextualizes some stories we've
already told helps us access
experiences maybe we haven't talked
about ever because we're looking at time
periods we've talked about before now
middle school but through the lens of
well what was that friendship like and
how is it developing what was the what
was the dynamic at that stage you know
so it kind of gets
at new things through that so i'm i'm
looking forward to it it's like therapy
without a therapist
uh
yeah i just think that you we t as we
said with the elementary school when you
tend to have this blanket statement
about being best friends and like oh
they were always so close and there was
they always had this dynamic but there
was
a development
yeah it was an evolution and
everything's changing in middle school
and i'm wondering how our perspectives
differ
on how that impacted our friendship uh
positively and negatively so
i want to get into that
uh but we should get into something else
first it's been a couple of weeks since
we launched the new mythical logo and we
thought this was the best form for us to
talk to each other
and to you
about the response that we got and
clarify a couple of things so kind of by
design
it's
it's been a few weeks been three weeks
ish
maybe a little bit more
since um
a lot of chatter and conversation
amongst the mythical beast has happened
but
so having kind of this
delayed conversation
is also something we can talk about
because that's the decision we made that
we just didn't want to like jump into
the fray but i guess we should set the
stage a little bit well
yeah i mean for those of you who don't
know
we uh
we changed the official mythical logo
a few weeks ago
um
and the first sort of indication that
that was happening i think is one of the
things that we got we got wrong
there was a uh so the way that it works
if you're a member of the mythical
society is you get a preview email of
what's to come whether that's new merch
or whatever in this case it was new
merch so you're the first to know of of
any any big
announcement in the world of mythicality
and so that mythical society members are
the first to know via this email and on
gmm on the following monday
what we were going to announce the logo
and announce the new merch collection
with the logo so on friday before a
holiday weekend essentially
which is typical we do if you're going
to announce something on monday that
email usually goes out the week before
an email was sent out
and the thing that was emphasized in the
email wasn't just that we were getting a
new logo but that
if you wanted to get randler merch
randler being the mascot
uh with the the the little mouse with
antlers and wings
it's been a mascot of mythicality for a
very long time
if you wanted to get randler merch you
need to act on it right now because that
was going away
now it may have said forever i don't i
don't know
i hope not but the implication was that
it was going away forever it was an
unfortunately worded thing right so it
seemed it was a
it was an email about merch that seemed
like it was an announcement about
the the new logo
which doesn't have the randler in it
being an announcement that the randler
was going away forever yeah and so when
in a live stream we're in the in the
live stream on the society the the we
did clarify this but very next week
which was on tuesday of that week
um
we did clarify
the wrangler is not going away because
that was one of the things that people
were really responding to and it was
just something that it was we're blaming
ourselves
for communi for accidentally seeming to
imply
that that was happening when what we
were trying to say is that that line
that iteration of the randler as it
exists as part of the company-wide logo
is going away so get it while you can
get it in the same way that we always
say about last chance stuff
um and i think there was a bit of a
marketing spin to it yeah that of course
we don't write these emails we can get
into this a little bit later this is but
um
yeah there was a bit of a marketing spin
that was like hey this is going away you
emphasize the scarcity of it if you want
this particular hoodie with this
particular rando logo on it we're not
making it anymore
but it got conflated with an
announcement about the logo in general
and
it it really the conversation
unfortunately became about the randler
going away
and
that was never the plan so
honestly it wasn't even an adjustment to
fan reaction it's like oh my gosh they
really love the randler so we got to
backtrack and say we're not taking it
away that that that was that was never
the plan to take it away but it wasn't
an adjustment we are taking
responsibility for the communication
that seemed to imply that that caused a
lot of consternation yeah so it's been
unfortunate i want to come back to
maybe a little bit more conversation
about what what why we decided to change
the logo and what we were thinking and
how we're feeling about that
but
while we're talking about
miscommunication i think it's probably a
good time to talk about a previous tweet
that went out like a week and a half
before the logo or a couple weeks before
the logo was announced yeah so now we're
talking five or six weeks ago but yeah i
mean
why not right uh
so there was a tweet that went out
that essentially said something along
the lines of
i mean if you want to read it just so we
could get it exactly right of what was
said and then we can tell you what we
were trying to say and then again what
we
unfortunately miscommunicated i think
the the big note here i don't think we
miscommunicated as much here i think it
was just left
it was too open to interpretation left
i'm on twitter but i'm my circle is art
i'm searching twitter on twitter dear
beast we value your enthusiasm and
hearing your feedback on all things
mythical
however lately we've seen a few of you
directing questions frustration and even
anger at members of the crew both on
their personal social accounts and
indirectly on public forums which is
unfair and not in the spirit of
mythicality please don't cross those
lines and always use the appropriate
company channels to raise your concerns
and constructive feedback
now and apparently this was this wasn't
as clear as we thought it was when we
uh
read it and said yeah this works because
the way that a lot of people interpreted
this and it is your right to interpret
it but we're in any way you want to but
we're going to clarify what we were
trying to say
uh to try to clear it up the way that a
lot of people interpret it as if we were
saying that you cannot criticize the
things that we produce as a company as a
media company who puts media out in the
world that we were trying to police what
you say of course not
i don't that's never been our intention
we understand that the whole idea is
when you make something for an audience
that audience has an opinion
and that uh the audience's opinion
matters and if it's negative
that matters and we take that into
account so i kind of think that's
uh wrapped up in we value your
enthusiasm and hearing your feedback on
all things mythical yeah yeah which is
kind of exactly what we said because i
just read it again
yeah but
but what what the line that we're
talking about is
maybe when it comes to you didn't you
didn't get
something customer service related or
like i'm i have a question about my
merch showing up or
a stipulation about something else
regarding like
in any of the any of the stuff that we
do from a customer stand yeah customer
service system specific we were talking
about
the stuff that we sell the merch that's
what we're talking about people get
upset about getting the wrong size not
getting something on time so
being delayed and then reaching out to
the members of the mythical crew who
that is their job they work in that
department but but tracking them down on
their personal socials or talking about
them
personally and you know just because you
know that somebody's job that doesn't
mean you go to the you cross the line to
their personal socials i don't even care
if they talk about their work and stuff
on that it's like everybody talks about
their their lives on their social that
doesn't mean that you can make it a pl
it's not a valid place for customer
support
um we have feedback we have provided
complaints we've pronounced those
provided official company
uh
avenues that you can go through to lodge
those complaints and those complaints
get heard and those complaints get
considered and answered absolutely um so
we want to pre we're sticking up for the
mythical crew here our team
to so that they can have a healthy
work-life balance so that fans
aren't coming or
aren't coming into their personal
timelines and in their personal space
uh online and these are specifically
people who aren't making complaints
public personalities so what there's a
distinction between someone who has
uh a show
right what we would call talent for lack
of a better word i hate that word
because it makes it seem like only
people on camera have talent but that's
just the
industry term for people who like have a
show
uh we're not saying you can't criticize
the shows that we that we make we're
just saying that if somebody works for
mythical in a non-public capacity yeah
and then you're reaching out to them on
their socials or you're talking about
them publicly we're standing up for them
and saying they didn't sign up for that
and we don't want them to be harassed
especially because we've provided
avenues and channels for you to
follow your computer not just harassment
it's even in even engagement
even polite engagement on your personal
side is is crossing a line that we want
to help preserve
their work-life balance and and
boundaries
you know so when it starts to intrude
it's like we want to stand up for our
employees and again there were some
things in that in the way that's worded
i completely get it you could think
that what we were saying is that we
don't want to be criticized
so if you took it that way we're again
we're blaming ourselves for
miscommunication the thing that we're
learning i'm not being too hard on
ourselves but it's uh you know it's
always i it's always hard to know
how things i am
okay so i am being hard on myself
so
uh because
this communication is incredibly
delicate right and also
i think
one of the things
that's hitting me
is
it is a really cool thing to have a
brand to have something that people care
about enough to have an opinion about
right that's a privileged position
to for people to care enough to have an
opinion about the decisions that you
make
is something that
ultimately that's the positive that i
take away from this is that well if you
didn't care you wouldn't say anything so
you you do care and so you are
passionately engaging and we appreciate
that
our end of the bargain needs to be that
we communicate things as clearly as
possible but it also is a little bit
daunting and it is the reason that we
did not immediately respond to all of
the comments about that tweet
and all of the comments about the logo
and the lack of the randle and all that
because
i mean 499 times out of 100
99 times out of 100
when you try to clarify and say
something else you end up saying
something else that you didn't mean to
say we're doing i'm sure i am 100 000
sure
that i'm saying something in the within
this 15-minute span that would be then
misinterpreted by someone else it is the
nature of communication
we waited so that the
the all the energy would die down a
little bit as opposed to getting into a
back and forth and trying to clarify
then oh well what about this and you
have to clarify and it becomes this
endless thing it's not an easy thing
so it's just like
we'll just wait a little bit and just
talk about it naturally the way that
we're that the way that we've processed
it
but not try to get into this back and
forth we're trying to clarify and just
end up digging a bigger hole than we've
already dug by miscommunicating in the
first place
now
so back to the logo well first of all as
a side note about that
about the tweet about team members and
boundaries like i was feeling bad for
trevor because all these people were
were uh it was all this conjecture about
well trevor just launched his podcast
and people are being hard on him it's
like i'm
i'm i'm ecstatic and my conversation is
with with trevor he's off to he's off to
the races man it's like he in and he's a
public persona that he can you know he
can take criticism publicly it's that's
the other side of the boundary the
appropriate side but that's not what it
was about at all it made it seem like we
were saying we just launched something
and you're not happy with it and so we
did not make it seem that way but it was
open it was open enough to
interpretation that people took it and
ran with it that way so it's like we i
just wish we'd been more specific but
again we didn't want
well we're being more specific now and i
again and i think we haven't really
talked about this that much but
my application my lesson learned is just
don't say anything i
honestly like
if
my my application moving forward is that
if i had to go back and do that again
i would try to
speak directly with the people who were
being singled out on twitter and helped
them develop
tools to deal with it rather than
bring making it a public thing which
just stirs up a bunch of stuff and
misinterpretation i don't know but you
know it's difficult to know what to do
it is and i think the other way to look
at it is
it's it's been confusing it hasn't been
perfect
and expectation of perfection and
communication is
is stupid but that is what the
expectation is okay but but to but it's
we can't we can't live up to that
standard but i think this process
maybe it's helpful for everybody because
i think you would agree that we're proud
that we
took up for our team members and that we
we're valuing even if even if we're
misinterpreted or people start to think
the wrong thing about us that we don't
want criticism i'd rather have that than
have our employees
be
be put in a compromising position and
that's why we did it and and having a so
i do think we made the right decision
that's why i retweeted it because i
don't i don't do a lot of twitter but
the reason i retweeted that was it's
like i i want those team members to know
that i care so i want to defend them
yeah so i don't wish we didn't do it i
just think that even though i don't want
to make it worse accidentally what we're
talking about right now i don't think
makes it worse i do think you can
clarify make things better and i think
that's what's happened
back to the logo and well would you
agree with that because the last thing
you said was if i had to do it over
again i wouldn't do it but i'm
counter-pointing that i agree with the
spirit of what you're saying but i don't
it depends on how people respond to this
conversation it's one of those things
that i'm just i'm i'm not smart enough
and i don't think that anyone in our
company is smart enough to communicate
in a way that will be completely
perfectly received by everyone
and so my tendency is just to be like
just do the things that you want to do
as a company don't explain the decisions
don't defend the decisions
because
it just feels like a lose-lose but
you know me i love to try to explain
myself i'm just i'm trying to learn how
to explain myself less well and to me i
think the thing that i value is an
understanding
with the mythical beast and if there's
if there's confusion if we're not on the
same page or if we're misunderstood
or if we're misunderstanding
them or individuals in the community
like you i want to resolve that you know
it it this it is a relationship which
again to come back to the logo
um
we're excited about the logo we like the
new logo it's it's very calculated in a
lot of ways
um it was never
um our intention
to
with taking the wrandler out of the logo
there was a rationale associated with
that but it was never our intention to
get rid of the randler entirely it never
it never even crossed our minds that was
not a conversation we had that we were
eradicating the randler we were just
trying to take the randler out of the
most the broadest and most outward
facing expression of mythical which
represents
us
and everything else that we produce and
everything else that we're going to
produce as a company we wanted something
that was broader and less specific
just for the broadest company logo
um and from a
from a
from an outward facing perspective your
logo communicates not to everybody on
the inside it communicates
a lot to the people on the outside who
are being introduced and
the fact of the matter is
the randler in that context
of an outward-facing logo
confused
conf it was confusing to people because
it's never heard of myth you've never
heard of mythical because it sent this
visual cue that like this is a fantasy
brand this is this might be a sci-fi
brand this might be it reinforces the
misconception that we're trying to use
the word mythical in the traditional
sense when in reality for all these
years we've been trying to redefine the
word mythical mythical doesn't mean the
traditional
make-believe
mythical creatures yes we use that
imagery as a fandom
because it just makes sense and it's
cool and mythical but content has zero
to do with that and so it's really
confusing to people when you're saying
this is who we are this is where we
stand for so this is a change it's
actually been a long time coming in
terms of thinking about yeah
like we we've recognized it both
internally and also as we've gone
through like brand exploration processes
we've learned that a lot of people when
they just see mythical and they see this
little magical creature there they think
oh these people must do some sort of
fantasy thing and so we're like okay
well that's not what we do we're a
light-hearted brand but that mascot is
important that mascot let me and le i
want to get to the mascot thing but just
to just just to sit a second with the
squiggly m
yeah and this new thing so we were
excited about that because it would
provide clarification
and i'll i'll go further to clarify
um
mythical
is
a place
that you can come to it is a it is where
curiosity
and comedy well create laughter and
curiosity and we can say it that way
it is it is where laughter and curiosity
create meaningful community yeah that's
what mythical means to us
right so
unfortunately by
making this headline in this one email
about the randler going away
parenthetically just within
the new merch line
you know
we
we confused things and we sent the the
absolute
backwards message to some mythical beast
who say and i fully acknowledge that the
randler to many of
many mythical beasts maybe you
means
it means that community it means that
connection like coming up with the
concept of the randler as a logo
naming it designing it designed by a fan
and then redesigned for one of our logo
for a couple of our logos over the years
and incorporating it into that
incorporating it into a lot of other
iconography as well
said this is a community this is
something that we're doing and
experiencing together and it's very
important to all of us
the the randler is one of many
representations of that it's not the
only one
but it is one and you know what i'm
we're very sentimental when it comes to
things like we're still celebrating 10
years of good mythical morning you know
even months later it's like
and
we're
we know that it all
hinges on the strength of our community
yeah so
uh it's it's we like fully agree with
the sentiment behind the feelings of the
randler but when you take it just but we
can also have a new logo that doesn't
have it in it and it doesn't mean that
community is not extremely important a
central part of what we're doing the
relationship that we have with mythical
beasts well to be specific is just as
important as as it's ever been and
ironically taking the randler out of the
largest broadest company-wide expression
isn't is intended to be a step towards
inclusivity right as opposed to
you see it and it's a barrier to entry
we back it backfired in the way we
communicated that now that does not mean
that you have to like the logo if you
don't like the logo you don't like the
logo like it i i totally get that
we can kind of explain what we do like
about the logo we you know
we like the fact that the m itself in
the mythical becomes the logo that
stands alone which that's not something
we ever had before
we had to use the whole word or we had
to just use the randler now we can use a
part of the word that actually stands
for for mythical
um we we like the way it looks we think
it communicates that it's like this is
like sort of a winding road and like
we're kind of just like
going at this by the seat of our pants
and we're definitely how we always feel
and we're very on this very long
winding journey that whole journey not
the destination thing
some people are experiencing have
noticed that there is seemingly a height
difference in the m that's relative to
me and link that's an illusion it's the
same height but that is both bumps that
is backwards well when we first
saw this logo we were like oh one of the
cool things about this is it's got like
our height difference in it but it's
technically backwards from the way that
fans experience it we thought about this
so we tried it the other way
everybody hated the way that it looked
including us but here's the thing that
we that it flipped a switch in my mind i
was like you know the cool thing about
keeping it this way
is that this is the perspective that you
would have on our height difference if
you were standing next to us looking in
the same direction
not
us over here and you over here looking
at us but if we all get on the same side
of the line get we all get a line on the
same perspective when we all start
moving together in the same direction
the ret and length height difference
would be the way that it is reflected in
the mythical logo to me again that was
another like aha this is actually if you
really stop and think about it even
cooler now that may sound like i'm just
trying to justify something
that's part of it but also when i saw it
that way and i was like this actually
becomes more meaningful to me
when i'm like well i'm embracing it
because i think it looks better but then
when i see that it has this other really
cool element
it's just like when you're reading a
poem and you're coming to your own
interpretation sure
that's how i'm seeing it now for me it's
cooler i love that
and it's yeah it's it's a symbol of
community yeah and we're all we're all
together they're facing the same the
same way and the randler's not dead
you don't have to um
he's not retired
uh he he's gonna be around and we're not
and we're definitely not ruling out that
he will come back in a new iteration or
on his own shirt or what you know
whatever it's like that was never the
intention so yeah and i love the randler
the randler's not going away randle
ain't going away he's
he's he's very special
um
but yeah from
yeah i don't want to keep getting into
it but like you think about belvedere
and like how he that mascot is
incorporated into good mythical mourning
intros and how that's changed over the
years and you know if he went away for
an intro
then he might come back for an intro it
doesn't you know it's it's not let's not
be so precious about this that we can't
change especially when we're excited
about
the the evolution of the brand and we
wanted a new logo and we like it so um
but there's so many things that we're
continuing to learn about communication
and having a growing team
and
i'm just being honest i'm not i'm not
throwing in i'm not trying to throw
anybody onto the bus i'm actually saying
what we have to learn in this and the
responsibility that we have to take is
that
you know when you have a team we gotta
you know
over a hundred people working for us uh
across mythical and smosh
and
sometimes
this there's
sensitivities might get missed or you
might be looking at something through a
certain lens of like okay i'm marketing
this this new these new line of
sweatshirts and people need to know that
the other ones are going away so you
kind of turn up the marketing in the in
the subject line that that we don't see
or approve
honestly yeah but it's and
because because we can't because we
would literally
sleep less than we already do if we were
to do it yeah
we can't do that and so
it was a mistake and mistakes are made
it's not the end of the world it's part
of the
it's something that we expect
and as leaders i think it's something
that we have to
we
we have to learn that it's part of the
equation but also say what are our
lessons learned here that we can convey
hey this
you know you may be newer to the team
and the team's growing but
this is what the wrandler means to
to mythical beasts yeah so there's a
level of sensitivity that
we could have killed so we could have
communicated yeah so it's a lesson we
could have done a better job it's a
lesson learned for us
we don't blame anybody
for misinterpreting it it was open to
misinterpretation uh we don't blame
anybody we don't have an issue with you
if you have an issue with this decision
we don't have an issue if you are mad
that the wrandler is not a part of that
company logo we don't have an issue if
you don't like the new logo i will say
that we are super excited about all of
that and our team is super excited about
it
uh so this is how we're moving forward
um but you know
that doesn't mean that you have to agree
and and we wouldn't expect you to agree
and it doesn't make you any less of a
mythical beast nope because you don't
agree i mean that's one of the things i
see some comments where people are like
you're not a mythical beast if you don't
agree with them
well no we're not we're not looking for
you know everybody to fall in line you
know we want you to be genuinely and
generally happy and excited about the
things that we're doing but we know that
the only people that we can please
all the time is us and it's not even
that easy for us to do that
but that's the only that's the only
barometer that we have is our own
personal interest
and desire and our team as well right so
that's how we decide what we're going to
do and we usually have a really good
barometer of how mythical beasts are
going to respond well but it kind of
it's a bit of a shake up that like these
two things were like
misses in terms of our sixth sense of
knowing how they're going to respond and
uh for different reasons
but uh again it's lessons learned for us
and i'm just super excited about where
about the future of musically i'm
i mean
mythical just get so confused lately i
don't know yeah i mean it's very
confusing uh
so thanks for hearing us out and thanks
for being patient and for trusting us
over the past three weeks if you didn't
hear
the little
uh
announcement in our live stream on the
society this may if it's the first you
hear into this thanks for trusting us
for the for the time it's taken
for this to come out i think that's
that's something we want to do slow the
pacing down here not no need to be as
reactive yeah like we have an
established relationship it doesn't just
because something shakes things up
doesn't
i i had to resist the urge i know you
did too to like to like
step in at the moment and like let's
make a video right now let's clarify
that weekend when we were seeing all the
comments
trust me we were together actually when
link got back from his weekend out of
town he came straight over to the
creative house on president's day when
no one was really supposed to be working
and we started figuring out what we were
going to say in a reaction in a response
video
and then we stopped
because we said listen we don't need to
get what we're going to do if we do this
is we're in an emotional place right now
and we're going to end up saying
something that we regret and we're going
to admit we're going to say something
else that's going to be misinterpreted
so let's just hold clarify this one
thing on the live stream and then let's
just talk about it on your biscuit and
we're going to
we're going
trust the mythical beasts
and then we're going to
trust that they're going to trust us in
the meantime
so i think i think this is more
relationship building
and a little bit of boundary setting too
so
okay i feel good about it sorry that
took uh all the time that it took but it
was like a was that like a businessman
it was a it was a mini it was a mini
podcast okay we're going to talk about
middle school rhett and link but first
we want to just uh
i don't know if this oh why don't you re
this will promote stevie's new podcast
which we want you to check out but let's
let's just go full ad read on this thing
because i like
the description of her podcast
every good coming of age story finds
except let me start over dang it man you
messed it up
every good coming of age story finds a
setting in high school in hallways
filled with lockers and anxiety school
dances with awkward poses first
relationships and heartbreaks
drivers licenses and drama club
lunchtime clicks and part-time jobs
there's something unifying about the
high school experience whether good or
bad and the people you spend it with for
some people those adolescent friends
become lifelong companions but for
others graduation day marks the end
and it did mark the end for stevie and
her high school best friend nagin until
now every week host stevie nguyen levine
from good mythical morning and nagin
i can't see i i'm i'm supposed to be the
announcer and no one told me how to
pronounce our last name okay thanks for
putting me in this situation
h
will unpack universal high school themes
and topics recounting their own personal
experiences and individual perspectives
in an effort to rekindle an old best
friendship fifteen years after they
parted ways in robes and mortarboards
it was a mortarboard i think that's the
graduation cap brother
can they bring their friendship back to
life
premieres friday march 18th
friday march 18th in the year 2022
stevie best friends back all right i
didn't even say the title i i i i stevie
and negan premiere best friends back all
right so it's like one of those tick
tock trends where it's like could you be
a voiceover artist and then you have to
like do something i completely failed
that tick tock trench this is not about
you this is about checking out her show
um
i
i'm excited about it i like that dynamic
of
what am i going to learn about their
friendship friendship and is it a new
fringe is the friendship going to work
now i mean and is is doing a podcast
going to make it easier or harder well
let's find out
you don't know
all right best friends back all right um
let's let's get into middle school so
for us middle school
was kind of a continuation of elementary
school bowie's creek elementary went
from kindergarten all the way through
eighth grade but there was the middle
school hallway the whole thing was
shaped like a
like a z
well a very straight z
like steps
and then you what is that that should be
a left but but why is that not a letter
so like the bottom right of your z is
the it's like an h with the two if you
look at an h and you just grab the top
end on the left and the bottom end on
the right and you tear them off yeah
that should be a letter i guess like
knowing that layout of the school is not
really the thing i wanted to that was
that no i really spend that much time on
it but
over the years you would move up the
elementary school hallway and then you
would you would start going to the next
hallway but that was like
fifth grade
maybe sixth grade but you weren't
considered definitely sixth grade but
you weren't considered middle school
there until seventh grade and the reason
is because that's when your class
schedule changed from one teacher all
day to multiple classes where you went
to three different teachers yep and we
were in the same class
for all of those so we moved around
together both years both years all of
the
yeah once you were in a class together
it kind of
that was you stayed in that lump yeah
but you got but you got a locker
yeah you got a locker rocket for the
first time you could play you could play
sports because that was when you could
like get on the basketball team or the
uh
before that
we
before that we had done recreation
soccer but this was like school soccer
yeah school baseball
school basketball and it was it was so
it was kind of cool that like your whole
um school career
you kind of saw this whole trajectory
and
you could see the
the middle schoolers you could see those
eighth graders coming into the lunchroom
and stuff so it was like
it
you really had something to aspire to
because it was right there in front of
you and it wasn't a huge scary deal to
go to the middle school because it was
just going further down the hall it was
one of the more easy it was the easier
transition i can think of for most
people having to go to like a whole new
place and new friends it's like is
everybody i was in school with before
with like the one new person from
nebraska that shows up you know to me
this is all wrapped up in the talent
show which we have talked about before
but at the end of the year
the the
it was the those three teachers were in
charge of putting the talent show on so
any student could sign up for what they
wanted to do and then there'd be that
assembly during school hours where
everybody would come in and sit in the
auditorium and the seventh and eighth
graders will perform their talents
and then i've been thinking about this
from
just intently from first grade oh yeah
because it's like
celebrities
in school celebrities getting up there
how and like performing us performing a
song and like there would always be this
big grim finale like the biggest act
would be at the end and you'd go in
there and you'd look you'd look forward
to it and then they would do it again
that night for the parents would come in
so you'd have two performances so by the
time i didn't even remember that yeah by
the time we were in seventh grade and we
had practice in sixth grade because the
fall festival where we did opp and made
it you down with halloween that was
sixth grade
and we talked our way into that
yep that there was not supposed to be a
performance of any kind
that thing and we were like we got to
get ready for this talent show we got to
know what it's like to be up on the
stage at this auditorium and perform for
a full house
yeah so by the time as seventh graders
we formed our posse and picked out our
rap song that we were gonna perform
we did uh we had a big posse we did
digital underground same song
which had tupac in it
and uh
then we added on and that and then
our friend ben greenwood he came out
with his uh
his uh drum machine
not on though
and he he didn't turn it on no because
we played the track that's right
and we played a second
we added a second song on to the end of
it or maybe that was eighth grade
seventh grade was huge because it was
our first year doing it and we like they
didn't put us last but they put us close
to last and like we we really showed up
the final act i don't even remember what
the eighth graders did everybody forgot
them by the time we were eighth grade we
knew we were going to do
so what's the what's the what's the
scenario by tribe called quest
yeah and we have more people in our
posse but it was a big deal and one of
the reasons we chose that was like that
was like a victory lap the seventh grade
like really coming of age we showed
songs that had different
parts different wrappers in it because
it was like you can represent like these
people can each be represented by
someone and so the scenario had what
like
four five people wrapping in it yeah
maybe six um
man those were the good old days so yeah
that so that just a picture oh gosh
that's who we were at the time we were
just thinking about being on stage
and performing and getting getting
attention
but also i was in a place where my sixth
grade year had ended with my first ever
girlfriend a one month long relationship
with leslie
there's a video on youtube because she
happens to be link's first girlfriend
too where we called her
and reminisced yeah on the vlog channel
um because yes seventh grade
yeah yeah i i found out we were in
different sixth grade classes i found
out you were dating her
and then
i was like
first of all this is how i find out like
you didn't tell me
like i that's an indication of like
sixth grade being in different classes
you start going with leslie and i didn't
know ahead of time that's an indicator
about like
that was just something that we didn't
talk about
you know i don't maybe we weren't close
maybe it was just something i was only
talking to the people that i felt were
necessary to pull it off which was her
best friend amber who then became my
girlfriend in eighth grade right but you
didn't talking to you about it wouldn't
have caused it to happen so there was no
reason to consult with you about it
unless we were like really good friends
right i didn't talk to anybody other
than tate i talked to tate because tate
was also interested in her oh you're
trying to box him out i did box him out
by telling him dude
i'm i'm i'm i'm well i think i said
something it's my turn may the best man
win but just so you know i'm also
interested i'm sure you didn't say me
the best man
but
my mentality now first of all that
relationship lasted one month there was
no hanky-panky there was nothing not
even a holding there was a holding of a
hand at one dance
that was it no kissing i wanted to it
didn't have the nerve
but i'm bringing the possibility of what
it's like to have finally been in a
relationship and
i've already made it very clear that
from very early on i was girl crazy
but the thing that i had was
the girl craziness without any game
whatsoever right i had no idea how to
talk to girls my go-to move was just
staring
um you know and waiting to see if they
stare back like it was i was so not good
and it's like the thing is is that
i was actually pretty sociable person
and i was oh i wanted to get up in front
of school and i wanted to give a speech
in front of class
i wasn't awkward in those settings but
when it came to women i just didn't know
how to proceed at all i just had this
really high level of desire and then no
game at all but but that did give you an
edge because
i think a lot of kids were still like me
i was very timid and i was like
frozen
but you weren't frozen you took action
yeah so my actions were my actions were
sort of characterized by timidity in one
sense though like like i don't know what
yeah but you do i'm going to talk to the
friend i did not i did not talk to
friends i did not you didn't i did
anything i didn't do anything so i'll
give you credit for that i mean i was
having a conversation with amber in
history class and she kept talking to me
about the boy she liked
to happen to be you and i kept i kept
trying to guess who it was
and i was guessing all these people and
then i i think i probably guessed
everybody except me until i realized it
was me and then we started going
together right because it was just i
never i it never it was never that easy
for me just so you just you know if it
hadn't been that i made it for me it was
so easy yeah i made it so if i hadn't
had the desire that i had
but then the level of interest from
girls that you had
you know what i would be the father of a
lot of children right now or something
something would it would be bad you know
what i'm saying that's not necessarily
bad having a lot of kids a full quiver
i mean okay yeah you're right proverbs
just say something like that um
but so in seventh grade
me and amber started going together
that's when i had my first kiss
at the uh
at the lilington
rubitan building for somebody's birthday
but who were you so seventh grade
seventh grade was a dry spell for me you
were you were you weren't even i was
primed and ready and uh pubed up and
everything
but uh
just i was
let me say there was primed and ready
and pubed there were things happening
there were things happening the plumbing
was working and the plumbing was working
often
i mean it was i tested it constantly
right great i was so ready
so ready
you weren't even testing your plumbing
at that time were you no
golly so much missed opportunity
no well i mean one tends to catch up
you won't ever catch up with me
i mean you could
you'd have to
die
your job
wow you'd have to quit your job to catch
up with me what do you do for a living
i'm just masturbating all the time to
try to catch up with rhett
you know what i'm not going to do that i
don't i don't advise it
i don't want it i've slowed down quite a
bit i don't want it to fall off
no no it's like it's like lifting
weights
it's like a bicep yeah the more you use
it is it is it though
well definitely if you don't want to
take a rash that's your right now but
your
if you don't if you don't have a
semi-regular release now first of all
you know nocturnal emissions will kind
of take care of it
in one sense but it's actually bad for
your prostate health to hold it in man
you got to let it flow
why let it flow
yeah i know you let it flow
i'm talking if you like if you're like
oh you're not currently in a
relationship and you know i'm just
saying let it flow
keep it keep the hose going
keep it going
okay uh and then but i mean you got a
girlfriend in eighth grade amber
yeah the same one you had in seventh
grade that's right
yeah and and that's when i started
dating so we are using first names now
huh cause we've we've talked about these
relationships so much the name's already
out there anna we got whole songs about
this oh yeah yeah yeah so anna became my
eighth grade girlfriend and i'm you know
i'm
i'm proud of her she's she's she was
always smart and i think now she's as
smart as ever she's the smartest of all
of us some sort of a lawyer situation
harvard yeah she's very smart uh i mean
which is indicated by her her long her
long term it never made a relationship
with me it never made sense to me but um
she was also very sweet so that's who we
were at the time
you were coming around a little bit
i was thinking about girls
non-stop
but our friendship was reaching a new
level because a couple of things number
one we were especially when you weren't
dating anybody we were so i think
seventh grade was an acceleration for us
yeah number number one we were in all
the same classes together which isn't
something that had happened consistently
because it was like every other year
would be in the same class as we
established on the last podcast
but another thing that was happening
jumping off of what we talked about last
time is our level of
sort of enthusiasm and seriousness about
our faith was taking off to kind of just
a little story to put this into
perspective i don't think i've ever
taught maybe i've talked about this but
around that time and i think it was the
summer between my seventh and eighth
grade year
i suddenly became
obsessed
with whether or not i was actually saved
this is a very common thing in like
evangelical circles especially like
baptist circles
where because you hear things from
adults like if you're not completely
sure that you're saved then you're lost
you're saying these really damaging
things to kids about their certainty
about you know
you're making their eternal salvation be
based on
a one-time event that they had to get
just right and i had
you know prayed the sinner's prayer and
done the whole i want to
jesus in my heart and forgive me of my
sins when i was like five years old so
for a lot of times in the back of my
mind i was like did i really understand
it
and i remember
being at a christian concert new song
um who came to the d rich auditorium at
campbell university where we saw many
concerts also saw a hypnosis one time
and i also
um
heavy-petted my girlfriend in the
balcony of this same place just to put
things in not in the same nice dedicated
not the same night
um
so
i was not at this new song concert oh
well you missed a show you missed a show
my mom actually was
five white guys with goatees singing in
harmony yeah and they're still around
new song is just they're like menudo
they just replace the members oh well
it's gotta stay new and um
so you went forward for a rededication
no i didn't again i i've always been i'm
more timid than you might think okay i'm
more timid than you might think
because
you got to check your pride to go
forward well the thing is is that what
happened was is they were like raise
your hand and come forward this is a
classic invitation where at the end of a
concert you haven't really done the
concert if you don't invite everybody to
make a personal decision for jesus right
then and there
and i've got this overwhelming feeling
that now is the time i gotta just make
sure i gotta make sure that i'm saved
i couldn't go forward because i was like
everybody i knew so many people there
and i was like i don't want to confuse
them and i do what are they gonna think
about me
so on the way home with my parents in
the car is when i said i started crying
and i was like i i don't think i don't
know if i'm saved and i really wanted to
go forward
well this is like seventh grade yeah
yeah yeah damn you like crying in the
car yeah mm-hmm because i
maybe we talked about it but i don't
think we talked about it
you might have said i read you know i
really dedicated my life
before that night
i remember that summer because i think
that that concert was it was either the
beginning of seventh or beginning of
eighth grade i can't remember the exact
i just remember that summer
i couldn't go and this is where i have
sympathy with people who have
obsessive-compulsive disorder and get
obsessed about one particular thing that
they maybe they think they got wrong or
they needed
having this thing that you kept i kept
going back to that the moment that my
mind would move off of whatever i was
directly engaged in
playing a video game shooting a
basketball
boom i would be hit with this oh man i
might die and go to hell and i've got to
get this right wow and it was
overwhelming it was really again i know
i don't have obsessive compulsive
disorder but it was this one time where
i was like
now that i've grown up and i understand
i know people who like my wife who have
it it's like oh man there was a build up
to it and did that did that new song
night give you the relief you desired
yeah i know i never thought about it
again sealed the deal i was because then
i was like i don't know when i got saved
if it was 5 or 14 and then as i got
older i unders i began to understand
more
about grace you know and understand that
like it's you know you think god was
sitting and if i was that worried about
it that was prominent i was probably
safe now of course i don't
believe any of that framework anymore
but at the time i very much believed it
it was the most important thing well it
does go to show i mean yeah in in our
involvement at church and in the youth
group and in the choir like they were
like sunday morning
for sunday school in church wednesday
night was
youth night thursday night was like the
choir night it's like we were still
involved in all these things and like
tim
was our new was our youth pastor and he
was like
he was like um he was bubbling over with
joy for all this he was like a super
sweet nice sincere guy and he wasn't he
was just he was enthusiastically in love
with jesus and and enthusiastically
all systems go on evangelism
and between him and
benny enzor who was involved he like he
was our choir director back then yeah
like middle school right and um you know
we were like this is so this is after
the bible tells the social stuff which
basic uh update on that
we have
we have the church play digitized
and we're going to find the right time
for us to do like a
a a participant commentary we didn't
direct it
on the mythical society because i think
with rights that's the best maybe the
only place we can do it so we'll let you
know when that happens you get sued by
the bible tells me show people tells me
so people well they are you think
they're still doing that show they are
they're very litigious yeah they might
be i don't know so
this was the age of by the time you get
in seventh and eighth grade you can
start to go on mission trips baby
oh yeah that was huge for us because not
only were we all the stuff that we had
been doing at church and like how
tight-knit our group of friends was that
had come up through all of the
indoctrination
now we were going out we're taking trips
in the summer
and
you didn't want to feel too guilty about
that last day where it felt like a
vacation because we were going there for
the lord's work after all it's called a
mission trip you're on a mission to
bring the love of jesus and salvation to
the people of the mountains of north
carolina or the mountains of west
virginia or
trinidad
[Music]
that's an island i've never been out of
the continental united states and here i
am in the first time yeah i think that
was after a eighth grade
year
but all of these mission trips were like
especially trinidad these are like big
moments of
all of us taking this huge risk where
it's like what is tim going to ask us to
do well he's going to ask us to like he
was throwing accelerant on your the
spark of your faith right that's what
that's you know
the the honest perspective on this and
every youth pastor knows this is that
these mission trips are not really about
the work that you're doing and they're
not really about the people that you're
reaching because most of the time you're
just talking to people who already know
and sure i mean yes there was a little
boy who i used a bracelet to bring to a
personal saving knowledge of jesus
christ at in trinidad you used a
bracelet you remember the bride you said
i'll give you this bracelet
no no we had the bracelet with the beads
on it and each bead represented a point
in the gospel do you remember what was
the first bead was
black
for sin
the second bead was red for blood of
jesus and then the next bead was white
for jesus cleanses your sin pretty
racist
by the way and then there's black before
sin white after sin but you know we
didn't pick up on that we were also
talking to kids in trinidad
yeah this is yeah i think it was still
work i think there was a green one for
like growth
yeah
there was a blue one for baptism
oh because blue was baptism
that was after
the the white was because you get saved
and then you make a decision for jesus
you make it to public decision right
with baptism and then green you grow i
think there was a yellow at some point i
think yellow was the rededication
the inevitable rededication
anyway i you so but what the point i'm
making is that
it's really about the way it solidifies
and accelerates your own faith like it's
those milestones that if you want your
youth group to like suddenly be on fire
you go somewhere together and you have a
you basically have a trauma bond
experience together and then you're all
in right you're going on this trip to
like this christian can't do the same
thing
but but
christian camp is
like you're not doing as much ministry
this is all it was all outward oriented
so like you were put in these like out
of your comfort zone every every day you
would go and let's paint this woman's
house
and i have a scar on my knee where i
stepped through a barber fence and like
ripped out a chunk of my knee
i always remember that trip to the
mountains of north carolina painting
that woman's house and i remember
some of us had to was like we got to go
up to the door and talk to her like we
got to make sure that she knows jesus
and just kind of having this sense of
mission and obligation and you know
you're serving people
but you're also trying to seal the deal
and yeah you either had a bracelet or
you would be taught to you could use the
five fingers on your hand
yeah that's cool so it's like
um put your thumb up thumbs up
i've got good news point your index
finger you're gonna die you're you're
going to hell
uh and then middle finger
i guess middle finger would be going
down the hill i think you it's like
so i don't know those first two are like
you're going to hell see yeah right bird
and the ring finger you've got to make a
commitment to jesus and then the pinky
is like you got a little now your faith
begins to grow it's a little faith but
that's probably not what it is it's
basically taking people down the romans
road but we want but
you see these tools that we were given
that then we had to put into practice
and every night we would come back and
we'd have these gospel in a hand as well
circles where we would do popcorn prayer
we would like
ask
we would share our experiences and pray
for one another and you know us as a
seventh grader it was very meaningful
because we didn't there wasn't a lot
that we had to care about that deeply
right again i think that's one of the
taking huge risks that's
why religion is so effective is that
there is this deep
longing for meaning right i mean i'm
sitting there just
whacking off every day
and thinking is this all there is it's
just whacking off i mean
it's okay but you're cool but you were
feeling horrible about it i was feeling
horrible i wasn't feeling as horrible
about it as i would in high school okay
that just got it got worse and worse but
what i'm what i'm getting at is i was
like
there's something
lasting and there's something deeper and
more meaningful and there's something
eternal that i can be a part of the work
that we're doing is eternal and we were
you and i
you know there was a group of friends
but like
there were more girls than guys
in our youth holly was a part of all
these trips well you're making a point
that there were older girls there were
high school girls
but not in a few guys on these trips too
but that was the other thing is this
like you're sitting there praying
for and hearing like this like high
school girl pray and maybe she'll pray
for me or maybe i can pray for her it
was intimate it was like it was it was
awesome but you and i were like the most
committed of our friend group especially
and we were like the only guys
who were who were as committed as we
were so it's like it very much resonated
with us and
became even more of a center point of
our friendship
right to bring it back to us the way
that we were connecting with each other
because
and i think this is when a certain
dynamic
from my perspective this is a dynamic
that was developing and i want to hear
what you think about this okay
so
you know
my parents were
together still are together
and my dad
you know the way i saw my dad was that
he had
he had the knowledge about everything
right like you want to know what to
think about politics you want to know
what to think about religion
he's got it figured out and he was he
was smart but he was also very assertive
in how he talked about it yeah he's
confident and so
i would sort of
take the things that he said
and yes the things that our youth pastor
said but it's just like you really want
to know what's the real deal you talk to
my dad
and then i would sort of assimilate that
into
the rep version which whatever and then
i would be like well
i've got to get link straightened out
about he's got to know what to think
about politics right because that
relates to
your faith and and the role and what god
is trying to do through politics in the
world but this is also this is what you
need to think about
predestination
you know this is what you need to think
about baptism i've got this information
now i've got to give it to you because
well you don't have a dad at home who's
telling you these things right so i've
got so and again right now this was not
a calculated thing and i never thought
about it that way but
that dynamic existed like i was getting
this information yeah and i and i had a
a willing recipient of that information
in you oh yeah i mean we we did talk
about beliefs a lot and
yes
the the whatever the dinner table
conversation was at your house about
politics or or religion like we would
talk about the next day and i would just
i'll be like okay yeah yeah yeah it's
like just
you know i was just looking for youth
pastor and
i guess your dad through you to just
yeah just just just tell me what to
believe give me the right answers you
know i'll ace this dest
you know this feels good
and it so yeah it was like
that was my predisposition and neither
one of us kind of lock in
neither one of us
had a
contrarian or questioning aspect to our
personality now i kind of developed that
over time obviously by
deconstructing and
there's a little bit of that in me that
came out but at the time it was like
that wasn't until like late college yeah
we had friends there were kids who were
already being like well hold up now
really this is what y'all this is what
we believe we just were just primed for
this is what we believe yes how do i
believe it really really hard how do i
align my life completely with it in
every every way it was like this is the
most important thing
never crossed my mind that it might not
be true yeah it was just like this is it
man this and and by you
what i was getting from you when i would
like if i would like bring something
like that was like oh he's just he's
just as serious about this as i am and
so we began to yeah
separate a little bit especially from
our guy friends right as these guys who
we would we did we took this seriously
and our that we began to bond
more aggressively because of the way
that we were separating and kind of
gravitating towards this view of our
faith
yeah and um seventh grade was the last
year that ben was in school before he
went to home school
i think it was another big he was easing
out
uh in the home school because of his
chronic fatigue syndrome and so by
eighth grade he was basically not there
he didn't go to church with us
but we would still
you know uh
he's still participating in the talent
show with us we still go to his house
and like
do dance routines and learn like rap
songs and stuff so i mean y'all were
still very tight but the amount of time
it was this point where we became more
of a three
sum well i would say friendship i think
we were more of a threesome earlier and
i think this is when
with ben's chronic fatigue there were
days when i would call over there and
mrs greenwood would answer the the uh
the phone and she'd be like ben it's not
ben can't do anything right now yeah and
as a seventh grader um
especially me i just wasn't i've never
been i i still haven't problems like
right we're talking to people so we
which we've already talked about that
but this is so so that ended up being
this thing where okay i'm not spending
this time with ben i'm not doing this
thing like every day during the summer
between fifth grade and sixth grade
i was going to be at ben's house doing
something and you would be there a lot
right but like the default was we're
going to keith hills to do something
and and that was changing now it became
this is when like in the book of
mythicality we're talking about you and
i right riding our bikes and meeting
at the midpoint at the middle of town
yeah and i had enough confidence as a
seventh grader to start riding my bike
everywhere and spending the night at
your house more often and that's when
like we would start doing the flashlight
wars and we would go to the keith hills
gate you would i would come along for
the things that you've been doing for
years with your neighborhood friends
like
setting off fireworks at the gate and
having the security guard show up
or like the campus police for campbell
university and they would get on the
loudspeaker and say
boys we know you're in the woods come
out i loved it and then i would start to
come out and realize i was the only one
walking out and then i wouldn't walk out
and then we'd like we would sprint back
to your house and i was so much slower
that me and your neighbor heather
weren't fast enough to keep up and we
got caught in the headlights of the
security car and then we had to go talk
to the security
guard
but he gave us a really strong lecture
and let us go because the re because you
ditched us yeah man you got i mean
everything for yourself
um so yeah i was kind of getting in the
mix there and and like having more
sleepovers
and starting starting to gain confidence
with me by the way and things didn't
register i don't think things registered
things registered with me in terms of
like because i remember basketball was
another thing where
like i mean we were definitely best
friends by this point and it was and
church was the engine and then school
was just icing on the cake but like
you were on the basketball team as a
seventh grader
and eighth grader of course but like uh
i find it wild that we did play soccer
together that's something that i tend to
forget i want to come back to the
basketball like you were the goalie
right yeah i had much to my
i didn't know you were like because you
were so big you can actually be up there
scoring goals man
and i played um
i i liked soccer i was pretty good at it
at defense
you know i couldn't run a lot i wasn't i
didn't have a lot of stamina hence the
uh security guard thing but i could
i could uh play some good defense yeah
because sports were becoming a really
big part of my life and of course i was
going to play everything that they were
they that we were allowed to play which
that was those were the three sports
soccer baseball and basketball and i was
just hanging on by the soccer thread
okay and again i didn't know that you
because we didn't talk about these
things now as a kid a parent of teenage
boys i get the fact that you're just not
there's a whole part of your brain that
you're not really using and you really
look back on these things reflectively
but but i'm thinking of things like
he's playing basketball
like and he practices basketball so much
like this really infringes on us being
able to hang out
i i
believe i'm pretty positive that the
reason why i started
keeping score for the girls basketball
team was because it gave me something to
do that like i was attached i would i
traveled with the basketball team with
the boys and girls and then so i could
go on the bus i got to go on the bus
and i could keep keep score for the
girls and then just watch the boys game
because i thought it was cooler to be
able to watch the boys game
versus keep up with it yeah
pandora though she was tough to keep up
with she's tough to keep up with it
machine yeah just just a layup tyrant
but
that wasn't that was part of my equation
you know it's like i want to be in the
mix i want to you know what's my what's
my middle school identity i'm okay with
being the score keeper if i can be on
the bus if i can be in the mix and you
were so you were processing things on
that level
i remember that yeah
yeah
to me but i also knew that i would never
talk about it because it's like talking
about your feelings and being being
needy is just a real sign of weakness
like
what what am i supposed to say it's like
well can i
can i do you think i can be a
scorekeeper but no so that we can we can
spend time together but but just to
clarify
aren't you like our kids talk about that
stuff
it's a it's it is very much a
generational and also a geographical
thing there's probably kids in certain
places in the world
and we're in our community that just
wasn't
how you process life as a kid right so
for me it was just like oh there's a
sport i can play it i can be good at it
okay it never crossed my mind that do it
do do i want like am i having fun it
wasn't about having fun it was about
winning it never crossed my mind it was
just like you have to be as good as you
possibly can at this
and of course you have to be as good as
you possibly can at this and you have to
be as good as you possibly can at this
and it wasn't just sports it's like oh
you also have to be as good as you
possibly can at academics you have to be
as good as you possibly can at the
talent show at giving a speech for the
class you
but it didn't feel like pressure
it just felt like a way of being it's
the yeah this is the plan
i mean and it was such a tight-knit
community like in our
uh middle school classes
uh seventh and eighth grade we had the
same three teachers miss wake us miss
mclamb and mr royal who was also the
basketball coach pe coach health teacher
um
and i
you know
the our group of friends
whenever something would happen or
there'd be like strife if there would be
drama with the girls
and sometimes it would involve guys and
dating and sometimes it would be us
doing like
stupid stuff
but
regardless of what happened that like
there was drama or trouble
all three teachers would take it upon
themselves to hold a tribunal to resolve
it they wouldn't send anybody to the
principal's office uh they were sparing
him because he had the rest of the
school and i think that they like to be
more heavy-handed than
he was
you remember if you were in one you'd be
in one class and all of a sudden
like a knock on the door and another
teacher would like call the teacher out
and then we just we'll be back in a
minute student and then
instead of coming back in she'll say
rhett
link
can you step out into the hall and then
we'd step out into the hall
and all three teachers would be there
like laying into us like like
questioning us about something we did or
and
sometimes it would be like calling the
girls out into the hall and there'll be
like six girls out in the hall with the
three teachers
just like
trying to have like a
a trip it's a tribunal they were put on
trial and it was kind of amazing i
remember this in general i don't
remember it as specifically as you do i
knew i remember when the six girls would
go okay well i know why these are the
six girls going out because they had a
sleepover but that one girl wasn't
invited and now she her feelings are
hurt so like that level of drama like
that middle school drama like the
teachers were like one of them was a
parent of one of our friends right one
of the girls in the group yeah and but
they were all like very involved and
like i never thought about that it was
like street justice yeah i don't
remember what the punishments were we
never really got i don't think much i
think it wasn't really punishments as
much as it was like the tribunal and the
lecture was the punishment
you know and then yeah because we never
got like suspended
no
uh because everything we were doing we
were all really we all made really good
grades and we were good we were
yeah which we definitely carried on in
high school but like
that middle school drama thing they were
it's just so fascinating they were so in
the weeds and it was uh
we're scared of them yeah and that's
when i was told when when you get to
high school next year they're gonna
they're gonna stuff you in a locker
well
as it relates to me and you
i mean i'm surprised that that didn't
happen but as it relates to me and you
i think that middle school is when
people begin to think of us as a duo
yeah right
yeah uh the teachers yeah that's why if
you got called into something i would
get and vice versa the the our friends
it's like oh yeah rhett and link they're
a duo
and
again this was not like an intentional
thing but it was like oh there's a
school dance
there's the lip sync contest it was like
oh well we're gonna do dj jazzy jeff and
the fresh prince because they're the
ultimate duo we're the ultimate duo
we started performing together we
started seeing ourselves as a team if we
could work together on a project like if
there was a way to be like hey we're
going to do this oedipus video that's
right and we used anna's video camera
and we did our first video and it was
like we were kind of thinking about it
in that way and then we did a whole
different one over at heather's house
yeah the next year
there was a corn field and like a
scarecrow yeah um but we started we just
naturally fell into this creative
partnership that's right hey that didn't
that really hadn't happened up until
that point right
it happened through the talent shows the
video projects
that was when we began to work together
creatively and i think that
now we had done things like the stupid
little radio shows and stuff at the
house right yeah the pause tapes but
what i found and of course i'm going
around i'm sampling every friendship you
know what i was doing i was going to
every single house i was spending the
night at everybody's house
and
i had in mind
not an agenda but i just i sort of just
naturally carried with me an agenda
without thinking about it
was just my personality to what
i want to have fun in a particular way i
am interested in having fun in this way
okay now we've got this radio i think
that we should do this radio show and
like we should do carrot we should do
voices and that kind of thing
there was no one else who was receptive
to that
besides you
i was all in
you know what i'm saying no one was
receptive to that way of thinking about
amusing themselves ben was ben was
well as we've discussed ben was even
more of an ideas guy yeah right and he
was more out there and like i mean
again when you go over to his house and
he's like let me show you the new dance
that i invented like and it's kind of
like river dance it's like i mean he was
he was a wild card he was amazing but
yeah i was very much like
yes i i had a sense of like
yeah we're gonna hang out we're gonna
we're gonna make stuff we're gonna do
stuff this is it this is it this is
amazing and regardless of what it was
this is a precursor to like the blood oh
thing but if we're yeah if we're gonna i
definitely had that sensitive we're
gonna hang out for an afternoon
whether it was you know me and you or or
the three ben was there or not it might
be like
all right we're not just getting
together like we're getting together and
today's mission is fill in the blank
go out and cut down a tree
try to make a raft that we're gonna
float in the backyard take some stuff
off of this tree and it might make a tea
that ben said we should make because we
found it in a book in the library yeah
we had missions we had agendas and then
it go into that sewer right it carried
it carried with a sense of mission and
then that was we we filled our time with
that way of thinking and then we also
filmed any
creative endeavor with the same sense of
mission like this is going to be good
and this has got to be the best thing
that we've ever done again we never
talked about it there was no like let's
have a meeting and figure this out right
it was in the natural thing
where
and then with ben sort of checking out
because of the health problems that he
was having i mean i still believe to
this day
that if ben had not had those issues we
the three of us would have grown up and
started something together yeah yeah i i
believe that it was something creative
together
but
yeah but what ended up happening
with the two of us were kind of left and
yeah because and then people started to
group us together
like that's when people would say
it would be rhett link rhett and link
this that and the other you know
a lot of weekends we would hang out we'd
spend the night at one person's house or
the other i think it started to happen a
whole lot right at this at this phase
and so it was this
identity
of oh these guys are a duo yeah i
definitely think that people thought of
it that way yeah and there's another
dynamic that started to develop at this
point
um
that i think is a dynamic that has
characterized a lot of our friendship
since that point
and we uh
we wrote this into the lost causes of
blake creek and the way that we
described the rex character
talking to the leaf character about
something
about the film school thing
it was and i remember the first time the
first time i can remember that this
happened was it was between eighth grade
and ninth grade so
we graduated from eighth grade and we
were getting ready to go to
to high school we were swimming in the
river like we did so often and so often
that summer it was just me and you
swimming in the river
no ben right
and
i was
casting vision
right for high school for high school
this is what high school is going to be
get ready and and i was doing it through
the lens of the women that we were going
to get to meet because
now it wasn't just all the girls that
we've known for eight years
it was the girls from lillington and the
girls from the girls that we've seen in
lafayette when you played them in
basketball
and the cheerleaders all the
cheerleaders and you saw the girls in
the stands and you saw
and hey i met a few score keeping girls
right mother schools smarty pants with
glasses on
now good with a pencil the and so i
remember sort of like trying to cast
this vision
and again that was when it kind of began
and then
i i feel like
i kind of carried this
this roll forward right oh yeah i
remember the specifics here's the vision
and this is the way you should be
thinking about it this is how you should
be getting excited about it and again so
you were this incredibly
receptive person yeah
that would
responded in a way that no one else
would respond to me
yeah
yeah no one else would listen to me in
the same way yeah and i was like
i i didn't just soak it up i did give it
back it was just like
okay you got you were on board
like you were like you know that that
cheerleader from from andrew melissa
like oh man she's
yeah she's here at the top of the
pyramid she's she yeah
and then
i remember we were talking about her i
remember two other girls we were talking
about specifically they were both in
relationships that didn't matter it
didn't matter i said those would not
last over the summer right i was right
uh
one of melissa stayed in a relationship
that did not pan out for me well because
your vision i think my vision too was
that i was gonna i was gonna date her we
had two girls that we were gonna date
together yeah mine didn't work out just
because she wasn't receptive to me
because
right i couldn't convince everyone of
everything at all times right
once they once they once they saw my
face
they'd be like okay well they're right
you better be something there might be
some other things going on stephanie's a
smart girl yeah right so we've already
said these names so i just could you
might as well go on record um
but yeah i do think that that's when it
really
when it really started to come together
like you talk about the accelerant of a
mission trip and like
we just took that mentality into our
friendship like we totally got
each other and we were going in the same
direction
we wanted we wanted the same things a
lot of it being attention and i was
scared as hell of girls but
i
every day i was i was uh i was getting
more ready to overcome that
it would take until 10th grade to do so
but we can talk about that
next time because i think this is a good
place to stop like the next time we pick
up this series of course we'll be in
high school
and
it that's an interesting phase because
our friendship our friend group grew
a lot
and
and then the things that we were
devoting our time to
like you no longer played soccer
and i didn't have anything to do with
keeping score for basketball like there
was more
uh i'll say threats to our our
closeness
in a lot of ways but then there were
some key things that counteracted that
so
you know we can walk through all that
and see what we can remember next time
we pick this up in like
i don't know in like a month and a half
we'll keep going at like that cadence
but okay
um
yeah yeah so middle school was big for
us man so i mean i think that the thing
that i had not the
the thing i want to remember
is a thing that i had forgotten
until talking about it which i think
that middle school is the beginning of
the duo yeah
that that that was the beginning of us
being seen as a duo
right that other people would have
perceived us in that way okay
specifically creative
not just a friend do a but a creative
duo
you know that middle school is a
formative yeah
all right what's your wreck um
my wreck is a wreck that you recommended
to me that i finally watched over the
weekend oh
chillin island
hbo max is that they got some good stuff
so when i see something i'm like on hbox
i might give that a shot especially if
it's like if it's featuring lil yachty
or young thug and i started with because
you told me to i started with a little
yachty episode which is what i'm gonna
recommend to you i don't know what the
first episode is and i don't know and i
didn't go back and watch it yet did you
watch the little tekka episode i watched
lil yachty then little tekka and i was
like i felt bad for a little tekka yes
but lil yachty is
listen i don't know
i don't know anything about lil yachty i
do other than what i've seen
is this one episode oh yeah and it's
like
what an incredible dude i love him
like i've
i met him at a at that video gamer award
show but like we got to have him on the
show yeah yeah for sure i mean talk
about a dude who just embraces is weird
yeah
he's great i mean he he's living on his
own plane
but the show
is so
interesting they're just not trying to
do any they're trying to do something
that is an innovative and three hosts
and it's just it's a it's a it's like a
mixed media thing because there's a
narrative that is unfolding that usually
has a make-believe element to it right
like the little yachty episode is sort
of centered around the yeti
the sasquatch
but then what they're doing is
unscripted like what they're talking
about is unscripted in the conversation
these i don't know who these guys are do
you know who those the guy the hosts are
like what's their background like who
they are
i think they're like podcast guys
they're like hip-hop community
uh
they're in that mix
but either radio or podcast guys i just
found myself thinking man i really think
i want us to be on an episode of this
and then i was just like
if we go if we go through the trouble of
like reaching out they wouldn't they
wouldn't even let us on because we're
not cool we're just too square or too
square you know they'd be like this what
those dudes from that show on youtube
like but i just i want them to know that
we're weird too and i and we like being
weird as much as we possibly can it's
just sometimes we are constrained and
can't
hbo max but you got really
self-conscious
as a place where you could i would just
love the fact that
they were talking about the kinds of
stuff that we talk about when we're with
our friends
and the conversations go to these places
these super philosophical and ridiculous
places where we just end up making
ourselves laugh a whole lot but
sometimes it feels like it's a prank on
the guest because like lil yachty or
whoever it is they don't they're clearly
unprepared for what's about to happen
and everybody else kind of knows the
itinerary i think lil yachty and little
teca represents two different ways to
approach it but here's the thing a
little tech is like
19 years old it's a it's a whole lot to
ask
and also to go on a fishing boat
oh god which i think they were next to
catalina it's probably where they were
yeah they didn't say that but it's not
it's not very deep
cohesive
fishing is really difficult to do and he
got sick and i was like i would have
gotten sick too this is
but like the lil yachty just because
he's all he's older and he
is a he's a little bit more comfortable
in his own skin yeah and that's why i
wanted to watch those two back to back
because once you appreciate a little
yachty then you really understand
how much on a lin out on a limb they're
going with what they did the little tech
oh and then the guy from vampire weekend
shows up yeah and this i just
didn't pay attention for a moment
and then i was like who is this guy yeah
and then once you started trying to
explain his one song i was like oh
that's the dude from vampire weekend yes
he showed up pretty funny i it's the
kind of thing that we would envision
this is the this is what i watched it i
did one of those things where i watch it
and i was self-conscious about two
things one how i wanted to be on the
show and two how i want to make a show
like that
uh
but then you just depending on who
you're trying to make a show for they
will tell you that like this isn't this
is too weird for us right i just i love
what hbo is doing because they're just
willing to just make something that
first of all
this isn't going to appeal to many of
many of you go and watch this show you'd
be like why did he recommend this but
some of you will be like
this is my jam
and so this is for those who will make
that decision and feel that way yeah all
right hashtag ear biscuits let us know
uh
i don't know what stood out to you from
our our middle school tales
and i know we're going to be talking
about the
the first part of this as well so we'll
get into that too on some hashtag your
biscuits to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]